well we can speak now to the former
chancellor ken clark who is now in the
house of lords thank you very much for
being uh with us
this evening mr clark
what was your reaction to what the
chancellor announced today
i thought it was okay
uh i was worried that he might get
carried away because the economy is in a
very uh worrying state uh and
the main job he has to achieve over the
next couple of years is to save us from
going into a recession or to back to
stagflation try to get us back to
healthy growth as soon as he can in this
uncertain world so he remain reasonably
responsible he's he he did have a bit to
play with because inflation actually has
been increasing his tax revenues uh
certainly you know in in numerical terms
and therefore he had a bit to play with
a bit he could do to help and he uh
you know we can all argue about the
actual mix he did some things i like
better than others but it was okay and
he keeps on he's a responsible sensible
man he does have a sense of the national
interest and you know where we are in a
couple years time as well as where we
might be tomorrow
you talk there about the you know the
need for caution effectively but as you
say there was this effective windfall of
around 20 billion pounds because of
increased tax revenues would you like to
see more helpful the very poorest the
people who are on the breadline who are
really going to be hit in the form of
rising energy bills i personally would
uh i did
you know
left might if i i've been doing it i
think i would have tried to resist the
five points off fuel tax which is rather
symbolic and as a result of pressure or
all the time uh because it because uh if
it's gone up by more than five p a day
or we'll be lost in the mix people will
forget it the day or two that he's
reduced the fuel tax at all and there'll
be another row in 12 months time
when he tries to
reinstate it
the one thing he didn't do that i think
i would have done is do something for
people on universal credit uh
there's very little in this for people
who've lost their job haven't got a job
uh the very poorest and what we don't
want as living standards are about to
drop in this acute crisis uh we don't
want to see more people going into
abject poverty so that's the one thing i
would have done and i probably wouldn't
have done the fuel tax
you talked there about
people going into real poverty i'm sure
you won't mind me saying describing you
as someone who's you know been a keen
observer of politics for some decades
now we're talking
we're talking about you know a drastic
fallen living standards that they're
most on record have you ever really seen
anything like this
now rishi's unlucky this is a completely
unprecedented in my lifetime certainly
in my political time uh um the economy
just keeps
being hit by severe blows uh har brexit
covid
now russian sanctions because of the
ukraine war
uh
these are dreadful blows and we're we're
about to see
uh huge surges in inflation uh certainly
the last two aren't the government's
fault but you have to steer the economy
through them and make sure it comes out
in a healthier state as soon as you
possibly can uh the the uh
that's why
he hasn't blown all
this
uh extra revenue described as
a windfall uh he hasn't continued to try
to get debt back to an acceptable
affordable level because as interest
rates go up debt's going to get more
expensive and he's
tried to get the total level of debt
continue falling compared with our gdp
uh what we need to do of course get back
to healthy growth with low inflation as
soon as possible but over the next
uncertain 12 months
we've no idea quite what to expect
because the ukrainian war is still going
on and there's worldwide disruption to
supply lines and worldwide inflation in
energy
costs so all that still to be coped with
he was right not to just blow the lot
i'm interested to get your view on
what's going on with taxes rishi sunak
says this is the biggest net cut to
personal taxes in over a quarter of a
century but the obr say that actually
the net tax cuts announced today only
offset a sixth of the tax risers
announced by this chancellor couldn't
rishi sunak really describe himself as a
tax cutting chancellor yet
well that was a hard sell uh i i mean he
he he's quite impressive the way he
tried to get it across that was
presentational no the obr are correct
um rishi had to spend enormous sums of
money on the furlough scheme which was a
huge success the economy could have
collapsed when we hit the brick wall of
lockdown almost two years ago then he
had to spend more enormous sums of money
on the health services deal with the
health consequences of the kovid
outbreak our debtors saw to an
extraordinary level and he has had to be
a tax raising chancellor this only
slightly offsets that
the other thing i think he was unwise to
do reckless to do
was to keep sticking to this cut in
income tax in two years time
he seems determined to cut income tax
before the next election
uh if he now he's announced it he's
going to have to stick to it
and that may involve doing all kinds of
things and or not being able to do
things that he might want to do over the
next two years and nothing wrong with a
20 pence
standard rate of income tax in my view
probably because that's the target i set
for it as i moved income tax down
towards it when i was chancellor but i
put up other taxes but i didn't have to
put up taxes to the the extent that
rishi has been forced to do presenting
it is a great tax cutting bonanza is um
you know
all part of salesmanship really but it's
not a frightfully accurate description
of the package
is it political you think this uh
or a coincidence that the income tax cut
comes in the same year as the election
well he keeps stressing that he wants to
reduce income tax before the election so
an income tax cut on his own sort of
buys an election result and he seems i
mean whether the prime minister is
pressing him for a popular
income tax cut on the eve of the
election i don't know
um but it's it's it's entirely political
uh to actually start saying now what
your tax position is going to be
in two years time at such an uncertain
moment in the middle of an acute crisis
is just tying your hands far far too
richly were he able to do it when he
could decide to do it in 2014 he's now
20-24
he's now committed himself the next two
years he's got to make provision for
a penny off the standard rate of income
tax whether he works in making the
government more popular would have been
what else is happening to the economy at
the time
i'm very interested to get your thoughts
on ukraine and the sanctions that the
international community has uh imposed
there's been some criticism of countries
such as germany for example for not
doing more on the energy they buy from
russia
do you feel that the international
community has gone far enough in the
sanctions against russia
i think if we can go further we should
uh i mean this is an acute acute
political crisis this is an historic
moment it's changed
it's changed the post-cold war politics
very much for the worst at the moment
the rules-based international order is
collapsing the globalized economy is you
know that's coming to an end that's
collapsing
and the russian attack in the ukraine is
the heart of this uh a a an aggression
into a neighboring state in order to
enforce it in back into satellite uh
status and if we decide that we can't
directly intervene with military
personnel
and help and we certainly should provide
them with the military equipment they
provide that they require
and sanctions
which at first were pathetic we were
taken by surprise by the british first
british sanctions were on three men who
were already been sanctioned by the
americans and five little banks
then public opinion was quite rightly
roused and public opinion drove
governments including the british
government into more serious sanctions
affecting russian banks affecting the
russian economy and we may well have to
do more
and we we do have to think i hope now
given that we had no policy at all
before this final invasion despite the
fact there'd been warfare inside ukraine
for the previous six years
this is why our first reaction was so
pathetic i hope now we're planning very
carefully for what we would do if we
fail to stop russia and russia begins to
take control
of ukraine and deal harshly with it
very quickly because we are at a time
but i get to talk to you so rarely i i
can't uh forgive me for squeezing one
more in i've never been doing interviews
so much recently by avoiding questions
on boris gate well this is just very
quickly and you can see it coming a mile
off and you said that the party gate
round the gatherings inside downing
street in lockdown fueled incredible
cynicism and that the prime minister is
in one hell of a mess is he still in one
hell of a mess or do you think all is
now forgotten that's one of the rare
occasions where the journalist got me to
answer questions on the subject uh i
think putin may well have rescued uh
boris johnson actually partygate will
come back
when eventually the met please stop
messing about and we're allowed to have
sue gray's report whether it will take
off again i'm not quite sure but i
continue to evade questions on boris
gate okay very sensible uh ken clark
thank you so much for your time today
thank you